My hematocrit is 33.9, range is 35 to 45.
Why is this low? And what can be done?
Well, there could be multiple reasons why your hematocrit can be low.
You'd want to look at that along with your red blood cell coat.
And your other CBC values.
So, I want to look at the rest of your CBC.
So, yeah, you don't look at just one blood value alone.
So, you want to look at the rest of the CBC.
Well, red blood cells and hemoglobin are also on the lower side.
So, then that tells us that you are quite possibly anemic.
So, hematocrit is measures the percentage of volume of red blood cells in a centrifuge contents of blood.
So, it's the part of the CBC that you look at the red blood cells, your hemoglobin, your red cell width, and such.
And your mean corecuscular volume, and your seribaritin, and your total ironmideic capacity to help determine if you have anemia.
So, if it's low, you could have iron deficiency anemia.
You could have vitamin B12 anemia.
You could have anemia due to blood loss.
You could have anemia due to increased destruction, which is typically called anemia of chronic disease.
So, anemia in cancer patients is typically from what's called anemia of chronic disease.
But, I think you have been dealing with a balance in anemia issue for a time.
And, wasn't it you that increased your red meat consumption and that helped?
So, you need different nutrients to be able to make red blood cells.
You need to be able to support the production of red blood cells.
But, whatever you have, decrease red blood cells, decrease hemoglobin, and other factors of anemia, you do want to look at, do I have bleeding issues?
Maybe it's because I'm a woman and I have heavy periods.
So, I'm losing blood that way. Am I making blood enough? Am I supporting blood production with my diet and my fasting too much?
What else could cause anemia damage because I did radiation, I'm doing chemotherapy.
Oxidizing agents can damage red blood cell production.
So, those of you want to look at causes of it, make sure you investigate causes.
Many times with stage four cancer patients, the cause really is that the cancer is just basically gobbling up red blood cells and gobbling up.
I heard and hemoglobin for oxygen. That's an oxygen carrying capacity of the blood.
And that's considered anemia of a chronic disease. And then you're always with cancer.
You're always like, should I add iron supplementation because that could possibly feed cancer.
If I do that, I want to add artimisticated with it, or should I just, you know, if I'm just kind of at that border, should I just, you know,
add more maybe red meat and beets and foods that can help build blood back.
And that is always what you want to do is your first step before you add iron supplementation.
You also want to look at ferritid.
If your ferritid levels are high, then you don't want to add iron because then you know you have an inflammatory process.
Remember I said B12 anemia can cause anemia patterns as well.
So deficiency in B12 and remember your genetics also have defects on, you know, MTHFR defects, MTR and MTRR defects.
Those are genes on the folate pathway and the path way that can cause a deficiency in B12.
Class, if one commonly overlooked issues and causes of anemia is a decrease in production of intrinsic factor.
Intrinsic factor is necessary for you to absorb B12.
So you might even be taking B12 but you're not absorbing it and you've got a B12 anemia because that.
Well, why would you have a decrease in intrinsic factor the number one reason why you'd have a decrease in intrinsic factor is is hypochloridria.
So you have a decrease hydrochloric acid production in your stomach.
You need hydrochloric acid, you need an acidic stomach in order to make intrinsic factor you need an acidic stomach in order to absorb iron and to absorb B12.
And remember, I've talked about this zoom call and some videos about hydrochloric acid that is the number one issue worldwide is especially in America because of our poor America diet is damage the cells, the pride of cells and the stomach that made hydrochloric acid and the number one problem is a decrease hydrochloric acid.
So you need to be taking hydrochloric acid and concurrently digestive enzymes with each meal can be the fix for anemia.
So make sure that you're taking HCl with each meal and you're taking it enough, many times people aren't taking it enough.
So the size of the meal you should take more so that can be the fix for anemia.
Talk to people that don't have cancer that suffered with anemia for decades and just fixing their stomach and hydrochloric acid production solves that problem.
And also people could have, you know, could suffer with symptoms from HCl for decades as well.
So that's always caused from tied to hypochloridria. So look at that. I actually have a video on hypochloridria and HCl and everything on the blog post so make sure you look at those.